vous ne portez plus offrez leur une
deuxième jeunesse quel pourrait être le
slogan de pauline alias madame ne t'ont
pas d'or depuis un peu plus d'un an
elles remettent en état et décors des
paires de chaussures l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on est dans une société qui est
assez consumériste et bien souvent on a
la plupart des gens ont des paires de
chaussures en cuir pour éviter de les
faire dormir et prendre la poussière
dans le plat car justement on les
ressort on leur redonne un petit coup de
peps et du coup les propriétaires seront
heureux de marcher dans la rue sont
jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui a
été en moyenne autour d'une centaine
d'euros pour une personnalisation une
activité que pauline exerce en parallèle
d'un emploi salarié mais les commandes
se multiplient ce matin là andré a bien
récupéré une paire achetée d'occasion
madame de pompadour à trouver en elle
une cliente ainsi qu'une partenaires
randria et ambassadrice d'une marque
qu'elle a elle même créé qui est se
nomme paulette sisters donc j'ai recréé
en fait son nouveau parce que c'était
son désir bien évidemment on a une
association qui s'appelle poulette
l'assaut et on a un grand désir de faire
découvrir les créatrices locale donc on
est surtout sur les prochains événements
que l'association organise pauline sera
toujours une de nos prestataires membres
créatrice de l'association qui sera
toujours mis en avant
si elle a commencé en peignant
principalement une marque de chaussures
britannique bien connu la créatrice
entend se diversifier en travaillant sa
clouzot et autres articles en cuir à
pâques